my guide to buying the best beef and
steaks
if you want the ultimate brunch you
can't do any better than start with a
perfect steak
and one man who really knows his steak
is master butcher
danny lidgate steak is my favorite type
of meat
and i think it's really good to enjoy
different varieties of steak
when choosing a steak that you want you
need to look at exactly what you want
out of it
for my ultimate steak sandwich i used to
fill it because it's the most tender
the philip does the least amount of work
than all the other muscles
is tucked away in the rib cage this
means that when you find a phillips
it's incredibly soft like butter it's
the most expensive
but you get what you pay for
there's a wide array of cuts to choose
from all different in taste and texture
if in doubt ask your butcher
this would be the rump section where the
rump comes from
which is basically the back side take
the bone out and what you're left with
is a wonderful steak
rum steak characteristically a little
bit tougher than the sirloin or a little
bit chewier than the rib eye
but a really strong flavor for the steak
again when frying rump
look for the marbling try and get some
fat covering on the steak
you can always cut it off after it's
cooked
rumps one of the best value steaks i
love it thinly cut and flash fried
in stir fries or simply marinated and
whacked on the barbecue
another great value but delicious cut is
the hangar steak
known as the butcher's cut because they
often keep it for themselves
it's great marinated and cooked quickly
[Music]
with the sirloin which is basically the
back of the animal
a nice sirloin like this really well
marbled
don't buy too lean so once the sirloin
is trimmed up
it looks something like this not too
much fat
but you need a little bit to cook in it
next to the sirloin
is the rib really popular now with rib
eyes
small nice really tender juicy
steaks it's really special for
barbecuing or grilling
fantastic probably my favorite steak
would be a ribeye
rib eye is especially delicious because
the marbling in the meat
loads it with flavor for a full-on steak
experience
try the t-bone steak with a small tender
fillet steak on one side
of the bone and a larger flavor some
sirloin on the other
[Music]
take your butcher's advice and you won't
go wrong the final word
has to go to danny when buying me
knowledge really is power so it's
important to ask as many questions about
the meet you're buying
find out the breed how it's aged
and decide exactly what you want to do
each particular job
that should then give you a really
amazing end product
one of my all-time favorites a dish that
always creates a stir
is the daddy of all brunches
steak sandwiches
[Music]
for me the secret of a great brunch is
fun and casual
fuss-free cooking and everyone helping
themselves
this is the ultimate steak sandwich you
want the rolls royce
of beef it has to be fillet now
season it beautifully i like to
open up the top of the peppermill to
increase the size
of the pepper in the steak so it gives
that bit of heat
nice little chunks you just roll now
nicely all the way around now slice the
garlic
in half pan nice and hot
olive oil in hold the steak
and just place it into the pan don't
drop it at the front of the pan
we're going to tilt the pan forward to
cook the back of the steak dual purpose
now roll it back
and sear underneath next
my garlic and roast that garlic
time fry that time i want to hear it
we're not looking for a lot of color
because you're going to dry out the fill
it so
just one end
turn it back down and stir the other end
in
lift up your time place it on top of the
garlic
there lift up your fillet and sit there
on top
of your garlic butter in
take a spoon tilt the pan gently
lift up and baste
i've got that scented garlic thyme
flavor
the steak is going gonna cook evenly
because it's sat on a little
a little bed in the oven for eight to
ten minutes
[Music]
pan on for the relish you think of a
steak sandwich you think of a sort of
nice heated tomato relish
to make the relish finely dice a red
onion three finger rule
one in front two behind
through and chop
wow next roughly chop a chilli
keeping the seeds in for extra heat
start off with the olive oil
into a pan onion
chilies
generous with the olive oil i want a
nice sort of rich
silky relish
from there take your tomatoes
you can't just use red tomatoes but
these yellow
and red make the perfect combination now
put your salt in cut that
and then roast those tomatoes off
take a wooden spoon and just sort of
break them up
once the skins blister the whole tomato
just starts to release all that really
nice
sweet texture a little teaspoon of
cherry vinegar
gives that nice acidic balance the
sweetness
of the tomatoes turn down the gas and
just let them sort of
stew perfectly now a steak sandwich
would not be complete
unless it had the most amazing mustard
mayonnaise
simply add three tablespoons of
mayonnaise to three teaspoons
of whole grain mustard
[Music]
now i've got the reddish almost down to
like a really nice jam
now i want to make that reddish a little
bit more fragrant
some basil slice it through
sprinkle that basil in there
beautiful
look at this
there she is my crown jewels
time to take it out smell
is incredible just based
one more time to fill it
touch is quite soft in the center so
it's just coming up to mid-rare let it
rest
at the same time you cooked it it'll be
nice and pink
evenly throughout the steak to make my
sandwich
i'm going to char grill some sliced
chipatta bread season it nicely
just a little drizzle of olive oil i
want to get that bread nice
and crispy pan nice and hot
bread in push it down
smell is amazing that char sort of
charcoal flavor
once you've got those marks on the bread
it just stops the bread from becoming
soggy
and look at this here it is
stunning on
slice it gently
one beautiful slice
wow it's nice and pink
all the way through and the beef is so
soft
it's almost like slicing through butter
let the knife do the work take a little
bit of mayonnaise
spread that the back of the spoon on
both sides
next lettuce
take that beautiful slice of beef
and then relish on top of that beef
and just slice the sandwich in half
beautiful now that's what i call a steak
sandwich
trust me serve the sublime sandwich for
brunch and you'll put a smile on
everyone's face
you